tristeza y dolor y un ambiente devastado
fue lo que se observó en la localidad de
Blend tire al sur de malawi durante el
último adiós a las víctimas del paso del
ciclón Freddy por ese territorio
es un momento muy difícil para nosotros
un momento doloroso y desmoralizador
porque no es fácil llorar tantas muertes
hemos perdido a muchas personas y se han
dañado muchas propiedades
una nación afectada por problemas
económicos y falta de alimentos previo a
la pandemia los organismos
multilaterales indicaban que un 74% de
sus habitantes se encontraban por debajo
del umbral de pobreza las autoridades
señalan que esta catástrofe les hará
retroceder en sus pocos avances
se encuentra en un estado de desastre
el ciclón Freddy nos ha hecho retroceder
cuando tratábamos de reconstruir
tragedias pasadas de la comunidad
internacional que nos mire con
benevolencia Porque necesitamos ayuda
en mozambique muy cerca de malawi la
situación no es distinta y el paso del
ciclón ha causado muerte y devastación
Asimismo desde la plaza San Pedro el
Papa Francisco pidió en sus oraciones
por Los afectados del desastre